(computer click)
(cheerful music)
- [Mark Ellisman] So, you may
ask what's that title about?
Well, when you are
asked for a title early,
sometimes you don't know
what you're going to say.
(laughter)
So, I figured I could say anything
and what I was thinking about was
Ramón y Cajal and what
he would have thought
beyond his great gift of seeing things
with the Golgi technique,
that we're actually hiding
in a forest of complexity.
That led him to speculate
and make predictions
that we're still following
in neurobiology today,
about how things actually connect.
If he were alive today,
he would be in wonderment,
if you like, regarding all
of the scales of details
that we can now describe,
with different kinds of
microscopies and labels.
And he would probably be, as I think
this conference is considering,
amazed at the gaps.
So, where are we limited
with regard to filling gaps
across either the spatial scales,
all the way from macromolecules to organs,
to the temporal scales.
And so today, I'm going to tell you
a little bit about filling a few gaps
all the way out to lifespans.
Two projects about dendritic spines
and about lifelong memories.
But I can't do this without
giving you a little background
on techniques at the national center
that Jennifer mentioned.
We use, really, two techniques
to do electron microscopy across scales.
One is Serial Section Electron Tomography,
where we take thick sections,
map them to get the best
X, Y, and Z resolution.
We look at systems that
can be manipulated.
So, here, a vestibular
hair cell is moving around.
That's what it's doing.
The top is rocking and
it's changing the output.
Or we use a method that was pioneered
by Winfried Denk called
Serial Block-Face Imaging.
You'll see an alternative of
this from Harold Hess, shortly,
where you can put a microtome
inside of a scanning EM
and just automatically record
image after image after image,
kind of like taking a look at a piece,
at a loaf of bread as you keep slicing it
and get a reconstruction
with modern methods.
If you selectively stain in a cell,
as was done by these colleagues.
This was a sample we imaged
when we first got this going
about ten years ago.
That's the endoplasmic reticulum
in the mitotic spindle and
if the endoplasmic reticulum
is stained, in this case,
with horseradish peroxidase,
you can then pick up,
those are mitochondria
those are lysosomes,
wait til you see the ER.
This cell's just in the
early stages of dividing.
Okay, so that's all the ER.
So, how do you find that stuff,
hiding in plain sight?
So, first,
unashamed pitch, we push this
technology quite a bit.
While Harold Hess pushed the technology,
he's gonna tell you about,
we've been pushing this
to higher and higher resolution
and bringing stains in, as you see here,
so that we can genetically mark components
in the context of this method.
We pushed it so that you
can look quite easily
at structures like the golgi apparatus
mitochondria, ER, but we've done that
through the benefit a long
collaboration with Roger Tsien,
from about the time Roger came to UCSD.
Even before the fluorescent proteins,
but then with families of proteins
coming up with ways of
marking genetically for EM.
And then, ultimately,
with Alice Ting, APEX
which is a small peroxidase.
Now, that was preceded by activity
trying something called, photooxidation.
Using a reactive generating probe,
something as simple as Eosin
to generate reactive oxygen
and capture diaminobenzidine,
which then can be reacted with
osmium tetroxide or ruthenium tetroxide
to give you electron density in locations.
At the scale of molecules,
we can see receptors
marked quite clearly with this method.
So, here's an example,
getting us into spines, now.
Eric Bushong, who's here in the audience,
when he was a graduate student in the lab,
now he's a senior scientist in the group,
tried out using phalloidin,
which binds to actin.
In this case, with fluorescein,
but also with Eosin,
we had it specially conjugated to give us
a way of doing actin by EM.
At that time, Francis
Crick had postulated 1982
that do spines twitch?
You can look this up. It's a beautiful
little theoretical paper,
which was Francis' best thing,
being a theoretician.
So these are all dendritic spines
marked by actin in a confocal microscope.
This cell, this is a purkinje cell,
was also injected just to
see it with the red dye.
And at that time, tomography was best done
with massive microscopes.
Here's a person for size reference.
(audience coos)
And we could punch through
with these very high energy
electrons, three million
volts, through samples
as thick as ten microns.
So, kind of a light microscopic sample,
but you can see inside.
This is from a fragile X animal model
and you can see how tortured
or variable the spines are.
That's a hallmark of that disease
in animal models or humans
and then if you switch
to the Eosin phalloidin,
do more or less the same thing.
That's the light microscopy.
Actin looks like it's all over.
It's not actually. It's
concentrated in the spines.
And if you punch through
it, this is not a tomogram
it's just a projection,
the spines are full
with this flocculant
material, that's actin.
It's not just filaments.
It's like we know in cells now, a gel
actually forms dodecahedral plates.
Okay, so, fast forward to today
we continue to develop these
techniques and the math
and Rick Lawrence is a mathematician.
Sebastian Phan, who I believe is here,
is a polymer physicist.
We developed software and methods and
automated these microscopes,
so that we take as many as
a thousand or two thousand
images of the same object.
So, by tilting the sample, rotating it,
kind of like having a thousand drones
in this room simultaneously
taking pictures of you,
then you have a super sampling.
So, this solves, to some extent,
what Daniel said, is the Z problem.
So, what you just saw play
was one of these volumes.
I'll show you another
one, but if you extract
the dendritic spine from that volume,
that's what it looks like,
okay, after you use some fancy tools
to follow the actin.
Okay, so that's the post-synaptic density.
This is a little finger-like process,
probably this guy was trying to extend.
But this is just a surfacing
of the actin, okay.
Here is a more recent
one, with something called
the direct detector, which
we invented at the Center.
So, here's the spine.
Head, neck, the shaft of the dendrite.
These are actin polymers.
The little balls you
see are actin monomers.
Here, you can even see if
you're close to the front,
membrane proteins in the membrane
and then this is extracellular matrix,
perhaps the perineuronal net,
that I'll talk about in a moment,
which you can see actually connects
from the extracellular space
to proteins in the membrane
on into the cytoskeleton.
That's the second part of the talk.
If you look at this as a volume,
now, that's just one slide,
you can see how rich this is
and how we extract it
with the right algorithms,
what you saw on the previous slide.
Okay, so, this is what we do today,
at even a higher resolution
than this to match up
to the molecular details that are coming
from structural biology.
But then to begin with different
cadence of experiments,
to look at what changes
during sleep, wakefulness
timescales that we can actually
stop action quite easily.
So, with colleagues in Munich
and in Stockholm,
we developed methods to extract
this kind of information in large scale.
This is just an example
of how this is done
slice by slice and you
can begin to study these
and consistency between
spines and different regions
or, as was published in science recently
by a group collaborating with us,
how this changes when
you sleep or are awake.
Spines shrink by 20% when you sleep.
More adventuresomely, we're saying okay,
if we know it's actin, or the majority
of what's there is actin,
what does it look like
if you substitute for the center lines
that we defined, for
the actin that you saw
in that previous colorful
spine spinning, actually actin
and does that tell us anything
about the charge and the crowding.
So, this is takin actin,
replacing all the threads,
this is actin from the PDB.
Why do we do that?
Because actin is highly
charged, very acidic
and this leads us to
predict that the actin
creates an ion binding matrix, a gel
and it's actually the saw gel changes
that may be driving a
lot of the physiology
that's interesting, okay,
so that's a speculation.
Moving on, back to that
extracellular matrix,
in a short amount of
time, I thought I'd try
and squeeze in what I think
is one of the most exciting projects,
kind of a leave from Roger,
this is what he and I,
and he was most excited
about when he died.
Project's now being led by
Varda Lev-Ram, who's here,
having to do with lifelong memories
and Martin Hetzer, who's also involved,
because these techniques overlap.
But Roger's hypothesis is
this and you can look it up,
it's in a paper postulating
that very longterm memories
might be stored in a pattern of holes
in the extracellular matrix.
The idea being that if
the extracellular matrix
holds state and the more dynamic things,
like Daniel talked about
and you'll hear more about,
know about the state of
that part of the brain,
then those things that
turn over will come back
or form those parts of cells,
guided by the extracellular matrix,
kind of like extracellular
matrix is the stone
that's chiseled in that gives
a durable state for the brain.
So, that was Roger's idea,
that this extracellular matrix
would be edited by Metallo
Proteases, synapses form,
synapses come to a shape
by activity or size,
predicted that the synaptic proteins,
pre and post-synaptic would
have short half lives,
relative to the extracellular matrix.
So, how do you test that?
How do you play with that?
Well, sorry, this is
just a little bit more
about the perineuronal net,
which had been described
by Cajal and others.
This is what it looks
like in light microscopy
with Wisteria floribunda
as a fluorescent stain.
And this is some of the molecules
that are known to be associated with it.
So, you can use proteomics
and look at that,
you can stain it. Sorry,
I got ahead of myself.
You can stain this the same way
that it was just done by light microscopy
by doing a peroxidase reaction to mark
that material in the extracellular space.
You can reconstruct it by the methods
that I showed you to
see what it looks like.
The synapses are in these holes
and then the question
is, does it stay around?
So, what Varda did following a protocol
that Martin Hetzer had first done
was create animals that
are 100% Nitrogen-15.
You're otherwise Nitrogen-14,
so this is kind of the
most expensive and heroic
pulse chase experiment.
You can see the paradigm here,
what is it, $800 a kilo for
food, something like that
and so these experiments
are, for the food, could be
$100,000 for a colony of sufficient size.
And then, at the right
point, after let's say
a six month or an 18 month
chase with the normal Nitrogen,
you sacrifice animals from the colony,
grind up their brains, do proteomics,
and then you're able to ask,
synaptic proteins have short half lives.
Those molecules that I said are part
of the extracellular matrix
at six months, still 30% of them.
At 18 months, they're decreasing,
but some of them are
quite significantly more
persistent than those constituents
that everybody's excited about,
it's synaptic plasticity,
which do turn over.
So, this is supportive
of Roger's hypothesis.
Can we image in 15 and 14?
So, then we went after tricks
that are done more in
geology or in astrophysics,
looking at meteorites or whatever.
Something that was taught to me
by a colleague, Victoria
Orphan at Cal Tech,
working on some samples from the ocean
and this is a machine
that uses a Cesium beam,
knocks out atoms, secondary ions,
runs them down something
like a mass spec column
and then point by point,
you get a collection
of masses for as many as
seven different atoms.
And you can make a map, okay?
So, one of the things that we tried,
Nick's postdoctoral
advisor, Jack McMahon okay,
so this goes back a way,
postulated and then proved
that Agrin, a molecule that secreted
into the extracellular matrix,
guides synapse formation for
the neuromuscular synapse.
So, we said, "well we
have intercostal muscles
from these mice, what do
the end plates look like?"
Do we see a signal from this method
that I just showed you? Yes, okay.
So, that would be predicted.
Here it shows you can do this.
We went from there, to
ask in these samples
from the mice that Varda grew,
what about this stuff,
this extracellular matrix,
is it old?
And here, you see, doing
the same sort of thing
on those samples, okay,
that indeed it is, okay.
And this, by they way, is myelin.
Myelin turns out, like you saw,
maybe if you were paying
attention to the bottom,
myelin basic protein to
other myelins are old.
So this is telling you,
if you look at the brain
and after the majority of
proteins have turned over,
six months, 18 months later,
what piece parts are left behind.
And here, this is the stuff
that is presumably left behind.
Turns over very slowly
and these terminals,
these boutons come in,
plug in, in between.
So this is, how would you say,
data that is headed in the direction
I think, of strongly
supporting Roger's postulate.
All of this is unpublished,
but I think it's exciting.
It's the product of, I
think, great thinking
by many investigators, great colleagues,
great collaborators, generous support.
This is the cast of characters,
some of whom are here,
and I think, with that,
maybe I ended early.
(applause)
- [Na Ji] I think we can all agree
that it is very difficult
to understand the brain.
Part of the reason is
because the sheer number
of neurons we have to study.
There's about 100 billion
stars in our galaxy,
but if you look at the human brain,
there's about the same number of neurons.
It's also about 100 billion,
but what makes it even more difficult
is that, on average,
each neuron is connected
with about 10,000 other neurons.
You might look at a much smaller brain,
for example that of a mouse,
there's still about
100 millions of neurons
with that forming about
100 billion connections.
What makes it difficult
to understand is not
just the sheer amount of numbers.
The theory is that all the mental activity
that really want to be able to understand
for example, perception,
attention, or consciousness,
is really an emergent property
of not just a few neurons, but instead
those millions up to billions of neurons
that form a neural
network or neural circuit
by forming connections with each other,
which we call synapses.
So, it's not enough to
only and try to understand
the you know 100 neurons,
even though you can
already learn a lot about the universe
by looking at 100 stars that
are formed at different stage.
So, condense all this into a
scientific question we can ask.
The first set of questions
we want to understand
is how a single neuron operates.
For example, the single neuron in a cortex
may receive 10,000 inputs.
We want to know what are those inputs
and we also want to know
how this individual neuron integrates
all the inputs it receives
to generate an output signal.
So, another way to ask the question is
what is the input output relationship
for the individual neuron in the brain?
After we understand
that, we can then look at
how multiple neurons,
actually tens of thousands
of neurons that are working together
by forming a circuit
and what are the inputs
those circuits receive and
how individual neurons,
within the circuit encode sensory stimuli
and execute a neural
command, a motor command.
So, in order to do that,
we really need to spend
a very large scale, both
in space and in time,
as Mark mentioned previously.
So, for imaging method, what
we would like to have is
we would like to have
sub-micron spatial resolution
because that is the size
of individual synapses.
Those are the size of the
connections between neurons,
but we also want to be able to have
millisecond-scale time resolution
because of how quickly the neural signal
may be happening in the brain.
We want to be able to image
those processes and depths
because the brain is a three dimensional,
rather thick structure, which are,
in all the adult brains,
they are also scattering.
So, one of the techniques
that has been around
for many years, which is
very powerful in this aspect,
is the so called two-photon
fluorescence microscopy.
So, this microscopy
relies on the excitation
of the fluorescent
molecule by the absorption
of two photons at the same time.
And then when the molecule
comes back to the ground state,
it will release its energy in the form
of a fluorescent photon.
The nice thing about this technique
is that the fluorescent signal
is only generated at the focus
of your excitation laser.
So, in order to form
an image of the brain,
what you only need to do is just to scan
this focus around the inside of the brain
and connect to the fluorescent
signal at each position
and then when you plot out this
two dimensional roster plot
that basically gives you
a micrograph of the fluorescent
molecule distribution.
As this example shows, you can see
that there's a special
resolution of this technique
is clearly sufficient,
since you are able to see
individual dendritic spines in vivo.
But there's a problem
when you try to image,
going beyond a two dimensional image
and this is important because,
from a single neuron to a neural circuit,
this is really a three
dimensional structure.
If you only scan in 2D
plane, you will only
be able to have cross
sectional view of the sample.
So, in order to get a volumetric
imaging of the neurons,
you basically need to scan,
you basically need to scan
this focus in three dimensions.
So, you can see that it takes time.
And, secondly, sometimes
your sample may be moving
and then you will have this
motion induced artifact
in your image.
And, finally, if you want to learn
how high volumetric imaging speed,
the traditional approach
is basically trying to move
this laser focus very
rapidly in three dimensions.
So, assume that you can do that.
What will then happen is
that now you will have
a huge amount of data, cause
you go from two dimensional
image now to a three
dimensional image stack.
And because of this motion problem
that you want to correct,
now you need to do
three dimensional motion registration,
which is very difficult to do when
you're dealing with gigabytes of data.
And typically, traditional
neurobiology laboratories
are not really equipped,
either in terms of
computation or hardware and expertise
to really handle this type of a big data.
And, finally, the actual
volume rate is still limited
by the brightness of the
fluorescent molecule.
Even if you can move
the focus very rapidly,
the focus is still required to stay
at each individual position
for a long enough time
for you to gather enough
photons to see the structure.
So when we were confronted
with this problem,
we ask ourselves this question,
is this traditional approach of scanning
this focus in 3D absolutely necessary?
And before I give you the answer,
I want show to show you that
those are the neurons in the brain
and you can see individual circles.
Those are individual cell body
of individual neurons and
those are the dendritic spines
of a single neuron.
So, there's lots of things happening.
You'll see flashes of
fluorescence intensity change,
which is basically telling you
that these neurons are becoming active.
But despite of all these activities,
you will probably also notice,
is that nothing is changing.
I'm sorry, the neurons
are not moving around.
I mean, lots of things are
changing, but neurons stay put,
maybe because of the actual [Inaudible]
that are holding them in space,
but they are so stationary that they are
even constantly, constantly
have the position
on the middle of a single synapse.
So, this means now we
actually have a choice
which is specifically true
if you have a sparsely labeled sample.
You could do this conventional scan
and then for a sparsely labeled sample,
you will spend lots of
time looking at nothing.
Or what you could do is to stretch out
your excitation focus so that
by scanning this focus
once in two dimensions
you will have a projected
view of the same volume.
But the advantage here is
that the imaging frame rate,
in this particular case,
is 30 frames per second
now becomes your volume rate.
So, here you are looking
at the volume of the brain
inside the awake behaving mouse
and you can see the neurons
become brighter and dimmer,
reflecting the activity
on this particular neuron.
So, this type of focus where we stretch it
in the axial direction is called
a Bessel focus or a Bessel beam
and this conventional type of focus
where it's very small
in the axial direction
is called Gaussian beam.
Now, Bessel beam is actually
not something very exotic.
When ever you go to the supermarket
and you go to the checkout line,
they will have this red light
that is reading the barcode.
Those red lights are
actually Bessel beams.
But so when we use this for
two photon fluorescence
microscopy, though,
we can't just use whatever is
inside the checkout
line of the supermarket.
So, what we did is that we
built a very simple module
that is located between
our excitation laser
and the two photon microscope.
I'm not going to go through the details,
but we use this middle equipment
called a spatial light modulator,
which allows us to generate a Bessel beam
of different lengths,
as well as narrowness.
So, here are just two examples.
On the right hand side, is
what an excitation focus
actually looks like in
the axial direction.
I just want to point out that this is
the actual size, you'll have to stretch
this whole thing by five times
because it's just too long to show it,
if I show you its real aspect ratio.
So, you can see when we
use a longer Bessel beam,
in this case about 60 micron
in the axial direction,
you can see more structures.
But one thing I want to point out,
is that you will compare
the image that you get
with what you have gotten with
the conventional approach.
You can notice that we
maintain the ability
to resolve individual synapses.
For example, there is
about 3 axonal boutons
in this Gaussian image, which is clearly
detected in the Bessel images, as well.
So, one big advantage of this approach
is that, now, the imaging
becomes insensitive
to the axial motions.
So what do I mean by that?
So, here are the images of a
stretch of dendrites in a mouse
taken with a Gaussian beam,
as well as, a Bessel beam.
So, you can see there's
quite a bit of motion
because this animal is awake
and hasn't been fully
habituated to have fixation.
And we can easily
register this image in 2D,
just to correct the matter of shift
and then, now you can sees
that it doesn't jitter
in the X Y direction as much.
And if you now plot out
the fluorescence intensity,
within this small stretch of dendrites,
you can see that in the Gaussian data,
you see this up and down signal
which actually looks very much like
the Calcium activity that
you would expect to see
when the neuron becomes active.
However, when you look at the Bessel data,
you don't see such up and,
those transient like variations.
Now, we could also quantify
how much the brain's moving
and when we do that, you actually realize
that all those transience we see here
are very strongly correlated
with motion of the brain.
So, then you can say well how do you know
this is not activity?
It could still be some kind of
motion induced activity of the neuron.
But we know, in this case,
it cannot be activity
because we are not expressing
Calcium indicating rises.
In this case, it's just very simple
yellow fluorescence protein.
So, by using a Bessel beam,
now really don't need to worry
about whether the data
you get is contaminated
by motion artifact or not.
So, as I mentioned before,
we have synaptic activity
and this will help us to do a subtype
of neuro biological experiment
where we ask the question of
what has a synaptic input
a single neuron receives?
So, here you are looking
at a 3D imaging stack
of the dendrites of a neuron.
You can see the dendritic spines
distributed at a different depth.
And the question here we are asking
is that what has orientation selectivity
each that synaptic, each dendritic spines.
What has orientation
selectivity of the inputs
each synaptic spines are receiving.
Now, if you want to
interrogate all the spines
within this volume using
the conventional approach,
the experiment is going to take
about 10 hours, but with Bessel beam,
we could probe the orientation selectivity
of those synaptic inputs
in a single session,
which will only take 20 minutes.
So, we have about 30 times the increase
of the output and if you
would analyze this data,
you can then gather the tuning property
of all the dendritic spines in one round
and, in this particular case,
we observe some clustering
of inputs of a similar type.
Now we are not limited to this
dendritic type of imaging.
Any kind of sparsely labeled sample
can be studied using this method.
So, here we are looking at
inhibitory neuron population
in the mouse brain and using
the conventional approach,
to probe the first 400
micron inhibitory neurons,
we need to take at least 80 images.
But with the Bessel approach, we only need
to take four images and by doing that,
in each imaging session, we
can gather lots of neurons.
And by looking at this
data, we very easily realize
this trend that is
there is a subpopulation
of neurons have very highly
synchronized activity.
So, if you are into interneurons,
then you will ask the question
that they are many
subtypes of interneurons.
We can label a particular
subtype called the VIP neuron
and you can again see
with the Bessel approach,
we can get all those VIP
neurons in one imaging session.
And when we look at the activity,
we actually found that those neurons
are highly synchronized
and we further discovered
that the activity is very much
correlated with the diameter
of the pupil of the mouse.
So, now what does that mean?
It is known that if
your pupils are dilated,
that means you are paying attention,
so I hope all your guys' pupils
are dilated at this moment.
But what we basically discovered is that
VIP neurons as a population has
extremely synchronized activity
reflecting the arousal level.
Now, if you are in the interneuron field,
then the cell type you want to look at
are the so called somatostatin neuron.
The reason is because the current model,
the most dominant model
is that the VIP neuron
will inhibit the somatostatin neuron.
If this model is correct,
then what you will expect
is that the somatostatin neuron's activity
to be always anti
correlated with the pupil.
But, that's not what we see.
We do see anti correlated the population
but we also see lots of the population
that are also correlated.
So, this means that this really a problem
with too simplistic a picture
and somatostatin neurons really only
have heterogeneous activity
that wasn't appreciated before.
Now, what we actually didn't set out
to make this discovery,
but because we can image
at a high support, this kind of conclusion
just naturally fall out of data
with a minimum amount of data analysis.
One thing that I think makes
this technique very powerful,
is that it is very easy to add
this capacity to our existing microscope.
So my postdoc Rongwen flew down
to Max Planck Florida Institute
and it took him only one day
to install a Bessel beam scanning module
on our commercial microscope
in the David Fitzpatrick mod
and because biology is much harder,
they spend a lot longer trying to gather
the high speed synaptic
imaging to work in a ferret.
So, since we published the results,
we've been helping multiple
labs to implement this method.
While we were doing that, we realized
there's two limitations
of the implementation
that we designed originally.
Number one is the limitation of money
because the spatial light modulator
is rather expensive, the
equipment is about $25,000.
Not every lab can easily come up
with the money to afford it.
Secondly, is the space,
especially for labs
that are using commercial microscopes
often time is a very compact design,
so it's difficult to fit
in an SLM-based module
into those space, into those space.
So, an alternative is to use the optics
that checkout line also uses is called
Axicon generator Bessel beam.
It's much cheaper and the whole module
is now only about $5,000
and it's very much smaller and compact.
But the problem with the
Axicon-based method is
you cannot really choose how long
your Bessel beam will be.
But my postdoc, Rongwen, figured out
that you can simply transmit a lens
inside the module and by doing that,
we can generate a Bessel beam
of different lengths very easily.
So, again here, you need
stretch out the focus
about 10 times to
appreciate the real length.
So, because this system is so compact,
we cannot easily implement
it on any kind of microscope.
One particular microscope
that is of interest here
is a mesoscope that was designed and built
by a group of correspondents
at the Janelia farm.
So, this microscope has a
very large field of view.
It's about five millimeters, which covers
about 50% of half of a
hemisphere of the cortex.
I also want to mention that there is
a remote focusing unit
there, which allows them
to very rapidly move the
focus in a Z direction.
So, we can combine the Bessel
module with the mesoscope.
This is how the whole module looks like
relative to the whole microscope
and now we can probe a very large volume
of neurons at a very high resolution.
For example, where we can zoom in
to this very large field of view
and you can still see, we
maintain the resolution
to see dendritic spines and just a few
nice movements by combining this
with functional imaging, now we can do
extra large volumetric
imaging at high speed.
So, this is 300 Gaussian
image frame of a single neuron
labeled in the mouse cortex
and we can just translate
the Bessel beam six times
and cover the same volume
and, in this case, we can
now monitor the activity,
while maintaining the ability
to see individual synapses.
And, remember at the beginning of my talk,
I mentioned that the goal
of being able to study
the input output relationship
of a single neuron,
now we really have the
technique to do that
on an awake behaving animal.
The very last example I wanna show,
is when we look at enough
just single neurons,
but also cell bodies in a circuit.
So, here we are looking
at extra large volume.
Those are the inhibitory neurons
from the first 650 micron
thick in the mouse brain
and we can image this whole volume,
1.3 millimeters by three
millimeters by 600 micron volume
of inhibitory neuron
activity ar one hertz.
And we're still doing this analysis,
but just, you know, subset of data
gives us about 1700 neuron
of the activity information.
So, I just wanna quickly summarize.
This work was made by the postdoc Rongwen
with help from many biologists
and collaborators both
inside and outside Janeila.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
- [Alipasha Vaziri] So, my lab
is interested in development
of new high speed volumetric
imaging techniques
with the goal of understanding
how neural circuits
give rise to behavior and
you have heard already
a number of fascinating talks today
and also the motivations
for why we need these tools.
For us, I just want to briefly summarize
also why from a biological point of view,
we are developing these techniques
and this is basically comes down to
what has been already
mentioned previously,
which is related to the incredible density
of the interconnectedness
of the neurons in the brain.
So, if we think about the human brain
that has about 80 billion neurons,
and we take out two of
the neurons randomly,
they are only connect to
two or three synapses.
And so this alone shows
us that, in many cases,
information may be not represented
by the individual elements of the systems,
but rather by states of the network
and therefore we
intrinsically to move forward
and record from many
neurons at the same time.
So, these are some of the questions
that we are interested in approaching
by developing these
technologies in the lab
and you have heard also
about parallel efforts
that are going on, on the
level of connectronics
that are related to understanding
the wiring diagram of the connectivity.
But I think connection will not
be answering us these questions.
It may be so the connectome,
may be putting us a constraint
on how we could approach this question,
but it will not be
sufficient to answer them
and the best example comes from C. elegans
that we also heard about.
The C. elegans had only 300 neurons.
The connectome is mapped out
already for over 30 years,
nevertheless we cannot predict
the behavior of C. elegans.
So that is really the motivation for us,
why we want to move forward and develop,
move towards functional
maps of neural circuits
and in particular, what is necessary,
is we need to have tools that
allow us to do two things.
On one hand, we want to be able to
do stimulation of defined
spatio-temporal patterns
of activity on a genetically
identical set of neurons
and combine that with a
parallel and unbiased recording
from an entire population
while we are doing that.
And you can also think about
if you had these tools,
how you would be going conceptually about
approaching some of these questions
and what we would like to do is
we would like to use methods from
machine learning, graph
theory, and information theory
to approach them.
So, in this example, you can imagine
that the first set of tools could allow
us to position ourselves in each
of these individual states
of these abstract space
that are the state's space and then
by having the ability to observe how
these points evolved to other points,
we could build over time
transition probability maps
that could inform us about the probability
of the transitions and use them to inform
models that could be generative
of the dynamics of the brain
and ultimately, what we are interested in,
to work towards discovery of
the underlying algorithms.
So, about seven, eight years ago,
when we started with this project,
we first focused on the first topic
and developed, basically
based on optogenetics,
methods that allowed us to
sculpt the distribution of light
and thereby stimulating
the individual neurons
at high speed and resolution.
And, moreover, the last few years
we have focused on the second topic,
which is the parallel
and unbiased recording
and here we have developed a portfolio
of different techniques
that are addressing
this question from the
level of small organisms
on C. elegans and more recently,
the more scattering brain of rodents
and you're moving also to
towards primate imaging.
So, and today I would like basically,
to give you a vignette
of some of the techniques
that we have developed,
mainly, around the idea of light sculpting
that has found application,
both in the smaller
semi-transparent C. Elegans,
but as I will show you, also
could be a useful technique
for imaging the rodent brain.
So, I would like to introduce
the basic idea of light sculpting
and those of you who are familiar
with optics and microscopy techniques,
quickly realize that in any kind of
microscope basically, the two parameters
that are describing the confinement
of the light in our sample
are defined by the, by two things.
One is the spot size of the beam
that we choose to
illuminate the sample with.
And the other one is the depth of field
or the axial confinement and you have
heard this also in many talks.
And with the problems that we are facing,
in some sense, is the fact that
these two parameters that
are fundamentally defining
the properties of lighting in the sample
are both given by the wavelength of light,
lambda, and the numerical
aperture of the optics
which is basically the ratio
between the diameter of the
lens and the focal length.
So, as such, the two
are inherently coupled
and so whenever we choose our spot size
to be a certain size, we inevitably end up
with a certain axial
confinement or depth of field.
And what we are basically asking is
how we can go beyond that and come up
with a technique that
can allow us to create
more arbitrary distributions
of light within the sample.
Now, as you have heard, the lambda
is the wavelength of light.
So, if we set also our wavelength fix,
then there is now way
around this coupling.
So we will end up inevitably,
for every given spot size
and every given depth of field.
However, if we go to
a different situation,
you have heard also about
two photon microscopy.
And in two photon microscopy,
it is typically based on
the use of femtosecond pulses of light
and the so called uncertainty relationship
which says if you choose
the time very short,
you end up with an uncertainty in energy
which translates uncertainty into colors,
means that if we use femtosecond pulses,
we are no longer dealing with
a single wavelength, but with a spectrum.
As you can see, at
least that by exploiting
that spectrum effectively is constrained,
as I was mentioning
before, could be relaxed.
And, so one way how this can be done
has been shown to be,
through the technique
of so called temporal focusing
that I would like to
introduce to you, briefly.
The basic idea is we use the
femtosecond pulses of light.
We send them to a dispersive element,
for instance a grating,
and what a grating does
is it sends the different
spectral components
within the pulse along
different spatial directions.
So, as the pulse is propagating
away from the grating,
the peak intensity drops off as a function
of propagation and this leads basically
to a dilution of the photons in space.
So, a pulse like that
is not very effective
in exciting the molecules.
So, we reduce the two photon
excitation probability
as a function of propagation.
Now we reverse the process
by using a telescope
that is consisting of a lens
and our microscope objective
and what that telescope
does is forms an image
here in the sample of our originally
short pulse on the grating.
So what that means is that there will be
only one plane in the axial location
where all the spectral components
will be, again, colocalized,
both in time and space,
leading to this high energetic pulse
that is very effective in
exciting the molecules,
but outside of that
region, we are basically
dealing with a disperse pulse
and such pulses are not very effective
in exciting the molecules.
So what we can achieve in this way,
we can achieve the
localization of excitation
in the axial direction by manipulating
the spectral properties of the pulse
and thereby basically decouple it
from the lateral confinement and have the
reserve the lateral confinement
to basically choose the spot size
that we are interested in the sample
by basically illuminating the pulse
on the grating with a different size.
Just to draw the comparison to
the standard two photon microscope
that you are more familiar with.
In the standard two photon microscope,
both the localization
laterally and axially,
are generated by their focusing
in space and in the temporal focusing.
The axial localization is generated
by manipulating the spectral
properties of the pulse
and laterally we can focus in space.
So, going to the problem of
large scale volumetric imaging,
we thought instead of now
exciting each of the neurons
at once and scanning it, we could use
that to create a sheet of light,
similar to Phillip's
light sheet microscopy.
In this case, we can create a sheet
that is spanning over about 75 microns
but still be axially confined
to about two microns.
So, the main difference is this is
a two photon excitation
and it doesn't require
the geometry that you saw before
where you have the two objectives
being orthogonal to each other.
So the idea was exciting a
field of view of that size
and then scanning that sheet axially,
quickly to capture the volume
and we wanted to use GCaMP
again as our Calcium indicator.
And the reason why we chose that size,
was that we were interested in looking at
the brain of C. elegans that is roughly,
that would fit in that volume.
So now if you want to
do two photon excitation
of a sheet of that size, this doesn't work
with the conventional laser sources
that people have been using for
two photon scanning microscopy.
You need significantly
higher pulse energies
and for that we used so called
regenerative amplifier that is shown here.
Basically it is seated by a conventional
two photon laser and what it does
is creates a significantly
higher pulse energies
but at the lower repetition rates.
And so the pulses are now sent
to the grating and here you
have the temporally focus,
focusing set up that I was describing.
And the fluorescence is now excited here
and then collected,
separated by a dichroic
and set to a detector
that we have designed
based on so called image
intensifier and a camera.
So, overall, you can see
that we can create now
a sheet that is about 75 microns
and being axially confined to two.
And what this allows us basically is to
go at very high speeds,
about 200 frames per second
or video rate volumetric image.
So, I said earlier, we wanted to
apply that to the brain of C. elegans,
and the neurons we wanted
to record from here
are located in the so called head ganglia
that are shown here and this was done
in a collaboration with
my former colleague,
Manuel Zimmer who is at IMP.
So, when we first expressed GCaMP
into all of these head ganglia neurons,
we saw that due to the incredible density
of the neurons and of the small size,
we couldn't distinguish them individually.
So, we came up with the idea of using
the nuclear localized version of GCaMP.
Basically, it has a nuclear
localization sequence
that drove the expression
of GCaMP into the nuclei
and then we could nicely
see that the neurons
were localized in all dimensions,
so we could apply our wide
field imaging technique.
And what I'm showing you here is now
a three dimensional maximum
intensity projection
of 120 neurons of the worm and
during spontaneous activity.
So, you see significant
spontaneous activity.
Certain neurons are correlated,
others are anticorrelated to each other
and this is all recorded at
about five volumes per second.
Our method can go about
four or five times faster,
but the neurons in C. elegans
have intrinsically low
responding or slow responding
time scales, so we chose to image them
at the lower frame rates.
Now if you have such a
high dimensional system
and you want to make sense out of it,
one simple way of asking what
are these neurons telling us
and what are they doing, is to do
dimensionality reduction and
one simple way of doing it
is to doing principal component analysis,
which is like asking what are the most
components in this system that
it can rise to the variance
that we are observing here.
So when we are doing PCA, we observe
that about 70% of the
variance of this data
was explainable by the first
three principal components
that are now shown here and here, you see
the color is encoding for the time.
Now, again, the great
advantage of C. elegans
comes from the fact that
we have the connectome,
so we can map this principal components
back to their known connectome.
And what we found was that
the first principal components
was basically an antagonism
between different interneurons
and head motor neurons.
The second principal component
was a class of head motor neurons
and the third principal component
was antagonism between
different head motor neurons.
And we could now display
these principal components
in the face space and what we observed
was an interesting behavior,
which showed sort of
a trajectory that was reproducible
and that was also characterized by regions
that resembled attractors,
which you can see now
in this movie much better,
as the states of the brain
are evolving, you see
that the brain seems to be
spending time in one of these attractors
and then it's switching
back and going to another
attractor, coming back again
and going on and on and so on.
So, this was an interesting observation,
and now we have increasing evidence,
mainly from the lab of
Manuel, who has been looking
also at these animals
during free behavior.
And what we know is these
attractors correspond
now to unique motor programs,
such as forwards crawling,
backward crawling, left and
right movement, and so on.
So, it seems that doing
spontaneous activity,
the brain is randomly switching
between these possible motor programs
and in the presence of the stimulus,
this landscape could be tilted
such that the probability of one of them
being a assumed with the
other, could be modulated.
So, we are following up on this
biologically and interestingly now
developing techniques that allow us
to observe this behavior during freely
free navigation as the animal
is making left right type of decisions
and see what kind of
things can we observe here.
So, while working on
this, we have been also
trying to push these methods further
and I would like to give you an overview
of another technique
and this is related to
how can we extend these
techniques into the mouse brain
and look at the larger
scale in scattering tissue.
So since you are, many
of you are familiar with
conventional two photon
scanning microscopy,
I just want to briefly take a moment
and outline the limitations,
the fundamental limitations
of two photon microscopy.
It's assumed that we would have
we were interested in
recording from a volume
that is about 500 micron cubed
and this would be about the size
of our diffraction limited spot
and we want to record from this
volume at about five hertz.
And now if you do the simple math,
these are 500 million
voxels and recording them
at five hertz requires a 2.5
gigahertz acquisition rate
and therefore if you wanna
at least excite each pixel
with one pulse, we would
need to have a laser
that runs at that repetition rate.
So, lasers are conventionally
not available at this rate,
but even if they would be,
you're facing another problem
that is that each individual
voxel will be spending
only .4 nanoseconds, which is about
an order of magnitude shorter
that the fluorescence life time.
It means we will not be able to
collect any fluorescence
out of this voxels.
So, one conceptual
solution that we need to
that we could employ here, is to minimize
the spatial resolution
or the sampling grate
to the limit of the structure of interest.
So if we are interested, for instance,
in recording from individual cell bodies
or from individual neurons,
this resolution, in some way,
may be too good and we are
paying the price for that
by having a reduced
volumetric acquisition rate.
So the question becomes in some way,
how can we relax the spatial resolution
in a meaningful manner?
So, cortical neurons are in the order
of about 10 to 15 microns
and this is the size
of the point split
function and in some ways,
people are mainly using that,
at least for this kind of imaging,
because they are mainly interested
in the axial sectioning capability.
So we could on principle,
relax the spatial resolution
laterally, by for instance, on the filling
the microscope objective,
but if we do that,
then we will soon end up with a beam
that is going axially about 70 microns
for the reasons I mentioned before.
So, what we really want
is to be able to have
to sculpt an isotropically,
isotropically sculpted
point split function,
laterally and axially.
And so and thereby, we
would also need to be able
to decouple again the lateral
from the axial confinement
and this is again where
light sculpting comes in.
So the idea here is now,
instead of sculpting
our point split function
to be a large sheet
as I was showing you before, in this case,
we would sculpt it to be
an isotropically shaped
five micron sphere, which shown here
and then we can scan
this by various methods.
This is a conventional
way, laterally and axially
to cover the volume.
So, going back to the
example that I showed you.
So the one million pixels
are now translating
at five hertz to about five
megahertz acquisition rate
and which is more realistically possible
with laser technology and also we get
a much higher pixel dwell
time at each of them
so we can collect significantly
more fluorescence.
So, nevertheless, if you look at the size
of this point split function, it's still
one hundred thirty times larger
than the conventional diffraction limited
point split function.
So, lasers that were developed for
that excitation wouldn't work here because
they're lacking in their
sufficient laser pulse energies.
So we built a laser in our own lab,
that was running at about 4.1 megahertz
and delivered .5 microjoule pulses
that are enough to excite these
sized point split functions
and this was integrated
into a scanned version
of the temporal focusing set up,
which is consisting basically of mirrors
that are then scanning the beam
that is illuminating the grating
together with the lens and the objective
is performing the temporal focusing
and we are scanning it up and
down with an objective pixel.
So, we collect now in the fluorescence
instead of on camera, from each of these
point split functions on the PMT
and the acquisition is also
synchronized with the excitation.
So we are running in the domain
that we have one pulse per pixel only.
So this is just an impression
of the home built laser
and it's integration
to the scanned temporal
focusing microscope.
Next, we were interested
in recording the activity
from in vivo in the mouse brain,
so we used mice in where we expressed
GCaMP in the motor cortical
areas and in the PPC,
while they were awake and were running.
So with this, we can now go deep
and look at the layer to three neurons
and record from them as you can see here
at about 200 microns depth,
from about 110 neurons or so.
We can go also deeper
to layer five neurons
at about 470 microns, record from
a similar number of neurons
and what is important here now
to realize is beyond
looking at a field of view
that is about 500 by 500
can capture at 160 hertz.
So, this is way too
fast for a single plane
given the slow response time of Calcium.
So what we could do is
to use the time instead
and look at two planes, for
instance, at the same time.
Which is now shown here, one at 150
the other one at 350 microns
recorded simultaneously.
Or going back to the example,
that I was outlining,
we can now go here and
record from a volume
that is now about 500 micron cubed
encompassing about 4,000 neurons
and record all of that at
about 3 hertz volumetric rate.
So, here you start also to see
the layered structure of the cortex,
the layer two three neurons
and the layer four neurons
that try to, that seem to come out here
and one of the things that we
are now collaborating with,
with other labs, is trying
to understand basically
how the cortex performs computation.
So we know that computation arises from
complicated interactions between different
layers of the cortical neurons,
but how that is exactly
done is not very clear.
So just to show you
what we can also observe
if you do some simple data analysis,
this is basically looking at the top .1%
cross-correlation within
the given time window.
What we observe are interesting
functional connectivities
or networks that are forming transiently
and also then changing over time.
Here the strength of these lines
are indicating the degree
of the correlation.
So one could look at
these things in principle
and ask how do they change on the
different behavioral states,
in the diseased states, and so on.
So, I just want to briefly summarize.
We saw that this idea of
light sculpting is possible
by decoupling the lateral from the axial
parameters of the beam and this allows
us in the Wiedefield configuration
is useful for recording at high speed
and semitransparent
organisms like C. elegans
and in combination with scanning,
it can be a method that
allows us to record
on the single cell resolution
from a large number of neurons
in the scattering brain.
Finally, I just want to
thank the people in the lab
who have been involved in doing the work
and our collaborators, as
well as our funding sources.
Thank you.
(applause)
(energetic music)